the nation's top infectious disease
expert that's Dr Anthony fouchy joins us
now Dr fouchy it's good to have you here
I know you're very busy so we thank you
for making the time let's start with one
of the leading vaccine candidates is now
on hold because of an adverse reaction
from one of the volunteers how
concerning is that to
you well I think it's important to point
out that that's the reason why you have
various phases of Trials to determine if
in fact these candidates are safe this
particular candidate from the as Zen
company had a serious adverse event
which means you put the rest of the
enrollment of individual volunteers on
hold until you can work out precisely
what went on you alert the other sites
to see if they see anything similar to
this or related to that and then you
proceed cautiously as you go forward
making sure you're on the alert for this
type of an adverse event but it's really
one of the safety valves that you have
on clinical trials such as this so it's
unfortunate that it happened hopefully
they'll work it out and be able to
proceed along with the remainder of the
trial but you don't know they need to
investigate it further how common is
it you know it's not uncommon at all I
mean we see this generally for the most
part but you don't know until you
investigate it it's an adverse event
that's related to something else that
just happened to have occurred during
the period of time that the clinical
trial was on but you can't presume that
you always make the presumption that
it's due directly to the actual vaccine
or therapeutic or whatever it is that's
in the clinical trial and that's the
reason why when we say we do careful
safety types of studies this is an
example of the kind of thing that you do
to make sure we're dealing with a
product that's safe I I remember you
told us weeks ago that you know we're
not we're operating on Corona virus
timeline line not our own we may be over
Corona but Corona is not over us so with
that in mind what are your thoughts on
when we can start thinking about a
vaccine you and the president seem to
have two different timelines here and I
think it's confusing for
people well well I hope it's not but but
let me try and see if we could clarify
it a bit I have said from the very
beginning given the way the trials have
emerged now and they are really on time
there are three candidates one of is the
one that we're talking about this
morning that now happens to be on hold
that's in a phase three trial namely an
advanced trial involving tens of
thousands of people to determine if it's
safe and effective the projection that
I've made and I'll stick by it is that
we would likely get an answer if this is
safe and effective by the end of the
year likely November December is it
possible is it conceivable that we could
find out earlier let's say October
certainly that's possible I think it's
unlikely but you can't rule it out I
think the more likely scenario is that
we will know by the end of this calendar
year and hopefully we'll be able to
start vaccinations in Earnest as we
begin 2021 many people are concerned Dr
fouchy that the the race to get the
vaccine has become very polit very
politicized listen you had
pharmaceutical companies coming out
yesterday saying listen safety comes
first you don't need to worry are you
concerned that it's now become very
politicized people don't know is it safe
to take it when is it safe to take
it well first of all obviously it's no
secret to anyone that we're dealing in a
very intense political atmosphere but I
think the issue that came out the other
day I believe it was yesterday or the
day before when the companies made the
agreement that they would not proceed to
try and get for example an emergency use
authorization unless they were convinced
that the vaccine was safe and effective
I think that's a good thing there are
also a bunch of safety valves along the
way for example there are independent
data and safety monitoring boards that
look at the data intermittently on a
regular basis to determine just what the
status of the trial is and when the
decision is made whether or not you're
going to give an eua which is an
emergency use authorization or even
approve the vaccine there are also
advisory boards that you rule that you
run this by so there's really a lot of
transparency in that so I do hope and I
believe there won't be a politization of
this it may be a political atmosphere
but I don't think we're going to have a
politization of the actual decisions
regarding a vaccine I sure hope so you
know but it is a very political climate
as you know the president continues to
hold these massive rallies where people
are not wearing masks including the
president himself when you see that what
do you think is it frustrating to you as
a as an expert on
this well yes it is and I've said that
often uh that situation is we we want to
set an example because we know we know
that when you do four or five typical
kind of Public Health measures masks
physical distance avoiding crowds making
sure you do most things outdoors versus
indoors those are the kind of things
that turn around surges and also prevent
us from getting surges so I certainly
would like to see a universal wearing of
masks Dr fouchy really good to see you
thank you so much stay safe stay sane
we'll see you next
time thank you very much for having me I
appreciate it